le théâtre pour redonner confiance en
soi et en l'école le collège sainte
thérèse du mesnil saint denis a mis en
place pour la seconde année consécutive
une représentation théâtrale pour la
quatrième à projets une classe réservée
aux élèves qui ont des difficultés dans
les processus d'apprentissage
ils sont intégrés dans une pièce
aménagée pour eux adapté du roman
germinal d'emile zola
il fallait qu'on trouve une oeuvre qui
soit une oeuvre de groupe et une oeuvre
qui soit du programme de français et
aussi à laquelle on puisse rattaché
toutes les disciplines et que voilà
cette oeuvre la cipr était
particulièrement par rapport à tout le
travail de en eps le travail en
physique-chimie sur le travail de la
mine
le travail en svt sur la germination sur
voilà toute la naissance de plantes et
puis après tout les paraît avec le monde
espagnols travaillent sur les grèves en
espagne en anglais les grèves sur elle
toute l'époque thatcher
avant d'intégrer la classe les élèves
ont signé un contrat d'engagement et ont
fait part de leur motivation
l'objectif du projet re prendre de
l'assurance en ses capacités tout en
respectant le programme scolaire
quand en théâtre on a plus de
possibilités de de courir deux on est
plus en a un peu plus libre mais faut
toujours se concentrer sur le texte en
fait on n'oublie jamais que l'école ça
sert vraiment à ça et qu'on est là et
bien qu'on va représenter dans une
semaine
alors faut toujours se concentrer ont
fait pas les imbéciles ont préparé le
spectacle les adolescents sont partis à
wallers sur le site minier où claude
berri a tourné germinal avec gérard
depardieu
ils ont été acteurs le temps d'un court
métrage représentation à découvrir ce
vendredi